This week, we will use the
concepts of momentum and energy
to examine an application of
great importance-- collisions.
A collision is an event where
two or more objects exert
forces on each other over
a short time interval,
and where the interaction
forces dominate
over any external forces.
Common examples are collisions
involving projectiles,
collisions of motor vehicles,
collisions in sports,
and collisions between atomic
or subatomic particles.
It is worth noting that the
colliding objects need not
actually touch each
other in the collision,
as long as the interaction force
does not require a contact.
For example, two
positively charged
protons shot towards each
other will repel each other due
to the Coulomb electric force.
Their interaction can be
treated as a collision
even if they never
actually touch.
We will see that momentum is
always conserved in a collision
as long as external forces
can be entirely neglected.
However, energy is not
necessarily conserved.
This leads to the distinction
between elastic collisions,
where energy is conserved,
and inelastic collisions,
where energy is not conserved.
We will also derive a simple,
but powerful principle
in the case of elastic
collisions in one dimension,
that the relative velocity
of one particle with respect
to the other is simply
reversed by the collision.